ankunft in schillingen castle schon von
außen sieht das schloss beeindruckend
aus vor 800 jahren wurde es als bastion
gegen die schotten gebaut war schauplatz
blutiger auseinandersetzungen auf jeden
fall der perfekte ort zu sein um sie
auch wirklich zu finden
mal sehen was uns heute hier passieren
wird denn es ist eines der berühmtesten
spur schlösser englands große fans aus
aller welt kommen hierher um etwas zu
erleben
heute scheint allerdings niemand hier zu
sein einsam ist es ein hausmeister mit
seiner familie wohnt hier und natürlich
der schlossherr selbst jahrzehntelang
stand schilling am castle leer
es ist der heutige besitzer vor 35
jahren übernahm und einige zimmer an
touristen vermietet
meine erste entdeckungstour überall
riecht es modrig überall hängen oder
stehen verstaubte antiquität
wer sich hier nicht gruselt den kann
wohl gar nichts mehr erschüttern
eigentlich ist es hier sehr sehr leise
aber irgendwas hört man immer zum
beispiel merkwürdige knarzen wirklich es
mein und dann bewegt sich auch noch eine
tür wie von geisterhand
aber ist das wirklich ein gespenst genau
weiß ich es nicht aber es scheint nur
der wind zu sein hoffentlich
nirgends eine menschenseele haft
die frau des hausmeisters stück hier
herum
draußen brennt wirklich überhaupt kein
nicht das macht es nicht besser
also es wirklich sehr sehr unheimlich
und zu allem überfluss habe ich
spätabends auch noch eine gespenster
tour mit einem erfahrenen geisterjäger
gebucht 19 andere teilnehmer auch aber
keiner schläft später im schloss die
glauben sie an geister hatte ja das ist
doch etwas zu lachen zurück und sie sind
gar nicht ängstlich
sie haben alle gut lachen die fand
später auch alles schön nach hause
grünen bernie führt uns jetzt zuerst
nach draußen in den wald verbrecher
verräter und völlig unschuldige wurden
hier an den bäumen aufgehängt in den
ästen so graham sollen immer wieder
geister erscheinen
trotzdem ist die stimmung noch
ausgelassen dann geht es in den
folterkellern hier ist eine menge blut
geflossen und der schlimmste folge
meister von allen john sayles soll noch
immer in schilling in kassel herumspuken
geist ist nicht an einen raum bauen
und wenn zum beispiel der geistes
futtermais dass hier von jemandem
fasziniert ist dann folgt den gästen
immer sagen ihr spuckt es überall nicht
nur einem raum der geist folgt einem
überall hin egal wo man sich befindet
sogar bis in die gäste appartements
jetzt geht es wirklich ans eingemachte
im kings ruhm und auch später in der
great hall sollen uns die geister jetzt
erscheinen und sogar anfassen und
deswegen macht graham das licht aus
er warnt uns die geister können sogar
beißen und kratzen
manche teilnehmer hören in der
dunkelheit jetzt stimmen klopfen und
fühlen berühren mich immer ganz sachte
hinter dem ohr gestreichelt hat aber ich
war überhaupt nicht ängstlich
seine unglaubliche erfahrung ich habe
etwas in der great hall gehört aus einer
ecke da war so ein knurren
ich habe jetzt nichts gespürt ich höre
jetzt eigentlich nur noch dass ich
furchtbar müde bin aber an schlaf ist
nicht zu denken
nicht eine sekunde komme ich zur ruhe
geister glaube ist offenbar ansteckend
am nächsten tag will ich es nochmal
wissen und gehe mit graham wieder in die
fensterlose kapelle licht aus und
tatsächlich direkt neben mir höre ich
wie jemand steine wirft
das kleine geister mädchen was da
offensichtlich spuckt hat in dem moment
drei mal ein stein geworfen sagt graham
und er sagt das wäre ein eindeutiges
zeichen dafür dass wir tatsächlich ein
geist begegnet ist